we're learning new details about the
murder very different kind of story
murder of a Pennsylvania man who
predicted his own death how did he do
that
in 2012 Frank Spencer was shot and
killed in his home just weeks after
signing divorce papers
now before his murder he received
numerous threats from his ex-wife maria
spencer he told friends he thought that
she would be behind his murder at home
Peter Van Sant investigates for this
week's 48 hours Pennsylvania State
Police corporals Shawn Williams was
assigned to lead the murder
investigation on the day Frank Spencer's
body was found Peter this is the Frank
Spencer residence the scene of the
murder
really unchanged since 2012 you can see
some of our chemical testing Frank
Spencer's blood spattered against this
frame and door can you get us inside
sure Frank Spencer's body was right here
on these tiles Frank's head was behind
this doorway and his arms were out
reached above his head he was laying on
his back Frank's friend Joe yo doc had
found his body this loss somebody you
knew from the time you were in
kindergarten can you put that in
warrants most of Frank's friends
including Dina Reed immediately
suspected Frank's ex wife Maria Spencer
we knew it was Maria we didn't know who
else might have been involved but we
knew it was her they knew Maria had been
threatening Frank for years police
gathered evidence confirming Maria's
possible role including her DNA inside a
cleaning glove at the scene you expect
to see a rubber glove in the kitchen but
not laying in the middle of the floor at
the house police also found a shoe print
that matched Maria's father
Rocco Franklin a rumored wise guy come
on I got no
Spencer before I had a beer out of
Broca's face a long time ago but
detectives needed more to make an arrest
as they gathered proof they got help
from this wedding crasher
it was Frank's dog Muttley who went
missing on the day of the murder and
then appeared close to Rocco's house at
a wedding but I'm that dumb Thunder
still a guy I'm supposed to whack taking
the dole and they were ten miles from my
house come on they don't even sound
right but that was exactly what police
say happened Peter that's a nice
question you get this tell ya motley is
the is the first dog that there's a
murder witness that I've ever met and
Muttley was found 70 miles from the
murder scene obviously the dog didn't
walk there so the belief is someone who
cared about the dog loved the dog took
the dog out of this this murder house so
we wouldn't be around Frank and cell
phone pinging discovered that Rocco's
phone was up in that area where the dog
crashed the wedding and that becomes a
crucial piece of evidence in this case
Wow you got me Rocco is a very colorful
character yes thank you very much well
we know how it turned out it appears to
see Peter support it's called Maria
Spencer's vow to kill that comes on
tomorrow right here on CBS at 9:00 at 10
o'clock 9 central on CBS